[Applause]
today we're going to talk about the
Democratic People's Republic of Korea
the only country in the world named
quite so ironically you may know it's
better as North Korea
it sounds democratic as they come free
ruled by the same family for 17 years
can be the head of state has been
inherited through three generations of
the portly Kim family Kim Il Sung Kim
jong-il and now kim jeong-hoon and in
keeping with this perfectly democratic
tradition the leader of North Korea is
called not president not king but
Supreme Leader you know just like any
normal democracy
so what can we really say at our North
Koreans that you haven't heard before
well it is one of the most brutal
dictatorships in the whole world where
mass torture execution and extreme
poverty are common and now you might ask
well why do we care so much about this
country well the answer to that is as
simple as nuclear bombs this is a
country that is still officially at war
with South Korea and makes a pastime of
threatening Japan and the u.s. with
nuclear annihilation and while that
might have sounded far-fetched at one
point in time with nuclear tests
happening almost every other year people
are starting to take a little old Kim a
bit more seriously but you still might
wonder if North Korea is that dangerous
well why isn't anyone stopping them well
they've actually tried basically every
sanction you could think of have been
thrown at North Korea instead of that
financial pressure forcing reform north
Korea has just had its diplomats selling
meth out of their embassies worldwide to
shockers very yes indeed there are North
Korean embassies and - yes indeed they
were selling drugs out of them but
there's one country that still calls
North Korea a friends and that country
is China they even have a treaty called
the sino North Korean mutual aid and
cooperation friendship treaty
China and North Korea are as close to
each other as lips are to teeth China
and to a lesser extent Russia have been
the only things propping up the North
Korean regime so damn us give China a
lot of sway over kim jeong-hoon right
well that's what the international
community sought and that's how China
came to be seen as the only country the
world could turn Singh in order to rein
in North Korea's nuclear ambitions
but well not so fast because things they
are changing and China is starting to
get a rather annoyed at their little
brothers Tom Marie
so the question today is what's behind
the cooling relationship between China
and North Korea and what consequences
could this have on the future of the
country
joining us today to answer these
questions is the biggest China expert on
YouTube yes the viewer we are talking
about Chris Chappell the host of China
uncensored hello Simon and hello to all
our friends at visual politics so
relations between these two communist
brothers have deteriorated so much the
China and North Korea are in the middle
of a war of work basically China said
that it would work with the evil
imperialist you know the us to combat
North Korea's nuclear program then North
Korean state run media responded that
China should really think about how its
reckless act of chopping down the pillar
of North Korea China relations could
have grave consequences and then Chinese
favor and media responded with a not so
subtle threat to end their alliance so
why is that they all they stabbing each
other in the back well we're going to
look at that right now
chyna friends owns North Korea China and
North Korea really makes the perfect
best friend they have much in common
they share a border they both had
communist uprisings and they have
installed leaders who have radical views
of Marxism the People's Republic of
China and the Democratic People's
Republic of Korea really are like the
Quentin Tarantino and Robert Rodriguez
of international politics especially
like we're doing a movie or something
doing you're with Robert is just the
idea that that's that year I get to hang
out with Robert now China does more than
just give North Korea financial aid
China has also made big loans of the
North Korean regime so they can build
railroads and highways and they're
pretty forgiving when Pyongyang can't
pay back its debt and then there's oil
for decades China was the main source of
Dino juice to North Korea
plus there's military cooperation
going to help train North Korean hackers
hackers who've now become a threat to
the international community including
China and what does Beijing get in
exchange well North Korea is a cheap
labor paradise in fact many products
with the made in China label should
actually say made in DPRK brilliant
sportswear brand Rip Curl made a public
apology this week after it emerged that
some of its key gear had been made in
one of North Korea state owned factories
but hold on a minute because things are
starting to change the Chinese Communist
Party today is a little less interested
in the global spread of communism and a
little more interested in becoming a
global superpower and North Korea is
well they're really cramping China's
style imagine how hard it is to be cool
with America when your good buddy North
Korea keeps threatening to blow them up
but this is not the end of the story
sixteen years ago China and North Korea
were pretty similar but today things are
quite different terrorists came to see
closely is the misery experienced by
their North Korean neighbors
I'm not old but I feel like what I can
see over there is similar to the very
difficult time that our nation had in
the past a lot of North Korean citizens
would do whatever it takes in order to
cross the Chinese border and Beijing is
scared what could become a refugee
crisis similar to that of Syria if this
wasn't enough
Pyongyang's diplomacy hasn't been all
that diplomatic with its own allies
here's a little snub courtesy of Kim
jong-un in 2015
in all-female North Korean pop bands
formed by leader Kim jong-un abruptly
canceled a Beijing concert on Saturday
and headed back home to Pyongyang
[Music]
unfortunately February 2017 became the
breaking points for this friendship
North Korea launching some ballistic
missiles are conducting some nuclear
tests is nothing new but what is due is
the degree to which China is willing to
criticize it this is happening at a time
when Chinese leader Xi Jinping is trying
to improve his relationship with the
United States and of course Kourtney
Pyongyang this is a stab in the back it
triggered the war hoards between these
two countries with state-run media in
both countries
criticizing the other but again this is
not the end of the story
remember those Chinese trained North
Korean hackers that allegedly hit
several Hollywood studios two years ago
well if you lay down with dogs don't be
surprised if you wake up with fleas the
wave of so-called ransomware attacks
that began Friday have struck China hard
if North Korea is responsible even
unintentionally it would be the first
known attempt by Pyongyang to digitally
pilfer China's coffers at such a scale
in other words by keeping things the
same North Korea is about to lose their
biggest ally the only country willing to
defend them in case of war and this is a
war even if just for propaganda reasons
a lot of people would love to start
[Music]
and Trump come in I I know what you're
thinking all assignment list is quite a
story and I need Batman Putin to become
a true visual politic video so well
Russia has already taken over the supply
of jet fuel to North Korea after China
halted exports two years ago according
to the industry sources in China Russia
and North Korea also have a lot of
things in common apart from sharing a
border they both have strong attractive
and manly leaders and in both countries
human rights are considered optional
Russia and North Korea just started a
ferry service to connect their two
countries so Russian companies can be
regularly stopped with a North Korean
slave workforce does that mean Putin and
Kim are now Betsey's well what if all
because Kim jong-un has a rather funny
concept of true love North Korea
launches a missile near Russian sea all
right
listen Kim jong-un dude this is really
not the way you make friends and as you
might imagine with things like this
Russia may not be too quick to become
North Korea's unconditional Ally and so
for the first time in its history the
most hated country has run out of allies
and this is where Donald Trump steps
into the picture we have a big problem
we have somebody that is not doing the
right thing and that's going to be my
responsibility this comes at a time when
China is trying to work on a new trade
deal with the United States at the same
time that Donald Trump is facing a lot
of pressure at home
so the question is now will Donald Trump
be taking responsibility for North Korea
to improve his image in the United
States could this be the end of the
North Korean dictatorship well you can
leave us your thoughts in the comment
section below we'd love to hear from you
meanwhile if you want to know all about
the details of the breakup between China
and North Korea don't forget to check
out my channel China uncensored China
uncensored is certainly the best channel
about politics in China on YouTube and
its really worth subscribing to if you
haven't already
so please do head over to their channel
check out their stuff and do subscribe
and if you haven't done it yet we also
hope that you think we are worth
subscribing to so please do hit that
subscribe button below this video and if
you did like this video do give us a
thumbs up and as always I'll see you
next time
[Music]